All right. Welcome to December. Beautiful weather here in Minnesota, Wisconsin area. We have snow on the ground. I hope you have a white Christmas as well.
Everybody to everybody to look at your member site and know that you have access to all the Zoom calls or all the Zoom calls but the courses as well.
All right. Let's jump into our questions. All Friday night into Saturday morning. I had sharp pains burning and grape bean within the tumor.
I hardly slept all that night. Sorry to hear that. All Saturday. I couldn't get comfortable. No matter how I position my body my tailbone hurt and cause aches throughout my body.
That night the pain went away and I slept very well for months. This is what this person calls this tumor has been purging lots of gray matter and fluids and always smelled foul like death.
And Saturday night the purging smell has changed to a chemical holder. And so is my breath that he thoughts on this.
Many times when you have like a little older, many times when you have a chemical holder, it can be because you're detoxing those chemicals. Some people have mentioned like a taste of metallic taste in their mouth.
And it's thought that you're detoxing heavy metals but it can be chemicals too. So when you're many, many chemicals, maybe many, many chemical pollutants like paint and and you know solve and some things have heavy metals in them and they'll give you that metallic chemical taste in your mouth.
It's your detoxing chemicals. It's not uncommon that you have that taste in your mouth and that smell and your tissues.
So that's not uncommon. It's quite possible that you're detoxing those things.
So that's one possible thing. Sunday I felt great today. I have been light headed three times when I stand up. You mentioned this can be linked to low blood pressure.
Can you have a great day and the next day light headed multiple times can little blood pressure fluctuate daily. So low blood pressure can fluctuate daily.
And also when you're light headed when you stand up, you have to think of it.
So get a CVC blood test to make sure your red blood cell count and your hemoglobin count is within fairly normal range is important too.
So light headed is when you wake up can be low blood pressure can be anemia can be extreme adrenal fatigue.
So your differential diet main differential diagnosis is light headed this upon arising.
So make sure you check into those things. When I feel my lump in my breast is everything that I'm feeling cancer or is some of its scar tissue inflammation thicker fatty tissue etc.
But another way I'm wondering if the size of what I feel with my fingers correlates at all with the measurements on my scans.
Well, I would agree with your assertation here you you don't know is it cancer or is it scar tissue is an inflammation is it just the inflammatory response of your immune system around the cancer.
That can definitely be true when you're feeling the lump when you're palpating the lump and it also can be definitely true with us with the MRI or CT scan the lump believe it or not that's what can give false positive enlargements.
We've talked about this lots of time before so I know that you guys have heard this but you got to be careful not to just take one test or one objective or subjective I need and then correlate it to you know your cancer getting worse you got away that with other things too.
So let's say okay the scan shows an enlargement I feel an enlargement my tumor markers are up my blood markers are off well it's probably pretty good chance to grow but if my scan shows a slight enlargement and but I feel great my tumor markers are actually better and my blood markers are good then you've got to go you know at least you have to ask the question is that a false
you know enlargement of the tumor and not a true enlargement is it because of the inflammatory response that everything that I'm doing to try to stimulate an immune response against the cancer is that really what's being measured.
You're never going to know that first with with complete certainty so that's where you have to you know not just be a technician like so many doctors are trained today just to be a technician they run this test that's what it says they look up in the computer what that means and then they follow their procedure basically to cover their tail instead of being the doctor well be of days gone by and try to ascertain through multiple sources and
and to give a better diagnosis so you have to kind of be that investigator in your own place in your own for your own body so yes it could be scar tissue inflammation etc it could be so you want to just weigh that out.
We did a cheek swab do I need to take pro hydroxychomology so the pro hydroxychomology is based upon your genetics typically so if that's what was recommended with your genetics I didn't change that so pro hydroxychomology is B12 so really there's no harm in taking B12 ever.
You really can't get too much B12 your body will flush it so there isn't any harm and continue to take it.
Do you remember I'm taking it to take four times a week is that spread out through the week or in a row typically that's in a row so you do Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday you take Friday Saturday Sunday does make a difference one days you take on typically it's done in a row that's good question.
So regarding feeling the tumor it sounded like this was back to this question sound like what you're saying even if the MRI doesn't distinguish between cancer and inflammation scar tissue etc is that correct it doesn't perfectly discriminate between those things it can show a false positive enlargement at time so nothing is perfect so if you ask the radiologist they'd say oh absolutely not I can tell if there's inflammation in there.
But in truth it's difficult to tell that so it can be inflammation that's around there that is a possibility one other blood results should we be monitoring besides tumor markers.
So other blood results that you should be monitoring besides tumor markers i'll get jumped out here is it's good to do CBC so a CBC is a complete blood count so a complete blood count measures your total red blood cells your hemoglobin your white blood cell in the breakout of all your white blood cells.
it's good to run that because anemia can be commented in cancer especially as the cans if the cancer is progressing so you want to make sure that you're not anemic want to make sure your white blood cell count isn't way off that you're playing the cult isn't way off so running a CBC is something that everybody should be running on them.
somewhat regular basis it's very inexpensive test to run it is the if you went into the ER for anything that'd be the first thing they'd run.
The second thing that they'd run is is a complete metabolic panel so a complete metabolic panel is going to look at all your liver markers it's going to look at you know the alkaline phosphatase and it's.
and your cholesterol and your albumin and globulin proteins in your blood it's going to give just another good picture now understand let's say let's say you didn't know you had cancer and you went in or.
let's say standard let's say I don't know maybe you're having symptoms and you went in and you did a CBC and a complete metabolic panel those most likely would be completely normal so there isn't anything in the CBC or the complete metabolic panel that guy ignoses cancer.
there are things though that are what are called ominous signs ominous signs and especially the complete metabolic panel would be would be lower blood proteins globulin and albumin lower.
let's say your cholesterol has always been about 200 and you go in for annual exam and your cholesterol is down to 120 you're not at any cholesterol or medication you haven't made any strong dietary changes that's an ominous sign and an ominous sign is an ominous sign for cancer.
and your albumin and globulin are are low that's an ominous sign so there are some some things that can point to different things that are not specifically cancer but they can point to different things if you already know you have cancer.
running those things would be a good thing now how often should you do that well if they're within normal range then maybe every three months if they're not within normal range then getting them run every month can be good especially if you have low hemoglobin and you're really keeping an eye on your if you have you know more.
moderate to severe anemia you should do it every month if you're if they're within all your tests are within normal range on your CBC and your complete metabolic panel maybe every three months would be a good idea.
at the doctor they said I should be eating kale instead of spinach I thought that was opposite which one should I be eating so.
should a cancer patient eat kale well kale is good for you right it's a good thing to eat it's was it's big in the vegan community kale has some really distinct benefits but what are those benefits the real distinct benefit of kale is the nitric oxide content there's more nitric oxide in kale then spinach about four times as much nitric oxide.
in kale then in spinach is that a good thing or a bad thing well it really depends on your diagnosis if you have cancer especially a hard cancer meaning not leukemia so if you have a cancer that is not leukemia you really shouldn't be eating a lot of kale because you really don't want to increase your nitric oxide levels.
well who would want to increase their nitric oxide levels if you don't have cancer nitric oxide is really good to help dilate blood vessels.
So nitric oxide would be the thing to take if you had high blood pressure so if you have high blood pressure and you don't have cancer kale is really great for you.
or even taking a nutritional supplement that has nitric oxide in it so that's huge benefits for blood pressure patients so people with high blood pressure people with with erectile dysfunction nitric oxide is the supplement to take but why would a cancer patients patient not want to take nitric oxide or eat kale which is.
out of all the foods that you can eat kale has more nitric oxide in it than anything else so why would a cancer patient not want nitric oxide because a nitric oxide increases what's called vascular endothelial growth factor or what's called veg F in short I write about this in my book veg F vascular endothelial growth factor helps stimulate growth of new vessels.
well that's exactly what you want if you have heart issues but that's not what you want if you have a hard cancer read your tumor a mass because it can increase the growth new blood vessels into the cancer and can help feed the cancer you know so the cancer continues to grow so you don't so I would not use kale if you have cancer now if there's something
something you're eating that is a little bit of kale in it that's fine but you don't want to make a group of kale smoothie you don't want to go out of your way to eat kale so cancer patients do not go out of their way to eat kale and you certainly wouldn't substitute kale for spinach.
I had read that arugula is also high in nitric oxide well arugula and spinach but kale is four times the amount of nitric oxide is spinach so I still would use make a spinach smoothie with cancer or arugula smoothie but if you're going to have some spinach leaves or arugula leaves in your salad that's fine if there's a little bit of kale in your salad that's fine just don't be you know going out of your way to to choose kale.
This question on the chat seems appropriate to talk about are you a rare of any supplements to ease the side effects of lorazapam withdrawal so lorazapam is an anti-depressant medication and the problem with it is that it and the class of medication that lorazapam falls under
can increase the amount of dopamine receptors on the neurons that's how it works it increases the amount of dopamine receptors on your neurons and that's the whole purpose of it the problem is is that it that isn't repairable so if you go off of it.
It can you can have some serious side effects of eat on it and you can have serious side effects of going off of it.
I'm not a fan of any of that class of medication for that reason and those neurons when they reproduce themselves they reproduce neurons that have that elevated amount of dopamine receptors on the the neuron which is not a good thing.
So it creates a dependency and creates literally a change in your brain that you can't you can't unchange so I'm not a fan of this whole class of medication is there some things that can help with withdrawal I'd say go to our website and look up or go to our YouTube channel or look up the
video called rated inflammation because the same things that you would do for microglial priding issues which the big word but you'll see an explanation of that in my video under rated inflammation I have a blog post about it but it's a video on YouTube would be the same.
It would be the same thing you would do to help with which are all of any of these type of medications that affect your brain.
I can't speak to the dosage of what you would do with the withdrawal I can speak to what you would do to help clean up your brain so I would follow this video.
I actually have the I can change my share let's see real quick do share let's do this let's try it let's do right there.
I actually had that slide because I'm actually talking about an interview that I'm doing today this is the video it's called um Euro inflammation that's what it's quite I think it's under rated inflammation on it.
On a blog post but it talks about M1 and M2 priming of your microglial and what to do about it and how to push sells the inflammatory process in the brain to M2 it's the same thing you would do to detox some of these anti anxiety antidepressant type medications.
You go through these phases of lifestyle try to very very very mild exercise and I talk about it in the video this is just the slide presentation.
Make sure this person's not taking any alcohol on stay away from pollution's talk that you can follow this video.
It's getting off of gluten and dairy completely because these are highly inflammatory considered going on a low histamine diet and running some other tests for anything that could cause inflammation in the brain so this would be the thing to help you hear some specific nutrients that have high amounts of the flavonoids that would help as well.
Okay let's see if I can switch back to our other share.
Okay so you can see back to our video again this share.
All right so what are your thoughts on simply all three water which is oxidized water 16 ounces a day I don't see any problem with that.
Again it's just also rated water I don't see that it's going to really help much past the stomach or first part of the small intestine but it's certainly not anything wrong with taking it and certainly won't upset the hydrochloric acid content of the stomach so there's nothing wrong with that.
I know that chemo does not kill cancer stem cells are certainly tumor cells but can kill these cancer stem cells so they don't come back with the flurry well that's what you're using the right for that's what you're doing all the the stimulation for that's what we're trying to accomplish with everything that we're trying to do.
So you're doing the right thing that's where it's so dangerous you know I've had patients that get a complete clean mill of health.
From their oncologist and they stop using the right it's like oh my gosh and then six months later the cancer comes back with the vengeance like okay I did not say that the right would have kept it at bay but I certainly think that's your best bet to keep these circulated tumor cells from taking off and you know raising the family you gotta continue to treat as if you're in the same situation so don't ever stop using your right.
So don't say okay to keep this in a low font because it's a lot of questions here I've been bloated perpetually for the longest time now that I could remember my stomach is extended in my tumor so large and inflamed they seem to go hand in hand together inflamed as two times they both went smaller and I'm wondering if I made a connection that could be possible.
The first time that both my stomach and my tumor this person has a tumor on their thyroid and so it's two completely different areas but they're they're you know trying to put this data together that whether when their stomach is bloated their tumor the thyroid gets larger and vice versa.
So first time was about five days after I began a complete water faster all the day I got a plant stomach back and noticed my tumor noticeably smaller and when swallowing second time was just now after being away for Thanksgiving five days eating the standard American diet including binge eating and gluten take off pizza and everything not healthy.
But the next morning when we arrived back home I was glad stomach and my tumor was much slower well that interesting these two things same in both these times is that I wasn't taking any supplements forgot them at the trip could it be possible that the supplements are causing me to be inflamed.
I'm back on taking this three days and my stomach and tumor are big again well it could be probably more than the supplements it could be maybe the capsules I have had people sensitive to the capsules and that's causing inflammation but has been pointed out which I had forgotten but I had said in passing about a year ago that I felt the supplements were making me bloat because I had stopped them for a bit.
When I ran out and it was fine then two I had made the comment geez I'm better without them or something like that I had forgotten because it was more than a joke not really thinking that it was why that I was just randomly bloated I'm truly starting to wonder if there's a connection very well could be so I would experiment a couple ways with this I would experiment never one I would start opening up any capsules that you can and putting them
and putting them putting in a smoothie and see if your bloating goes down let's say that makes a difference that it could be a sensitivity to the capsules even though they're natural capsules still I've had people had sensitivities to natural gel and to type capsules um secondly if let's say up and still a problem that I would just cut them all out again and see if the bloating goes down and I would add one at a time.
So you got to kind of distinguish what it is could be something and what the thing you're taking I don't know so that's what I would do I would do a process of elimination like that my original chief swam in March of 22 indicated heavy metals as a cause that may be true so I'm looking at your chart right now heavy metals are common cause of cancers at least
and in part like we talked about the first part of this chemicals you think well how do I get heavy metals there it it's so many things there are so many chemicals that we're exposed to too I do for another chief swam and a half way through having my Malcolm fillings removed should I wait until the fillings are removed no I would go ahead with it because we're not going to test for cause again so there's no need to so we're going to test for just a little bit more.
So I would still go ahead with it let me expound upon that question because people do ask a lot of times I have mercury fillings should I get those removes in general yes everybody should get their mercury fillings removed but you have to be healthy enough so if you're not doing well your cancers growing you're feeling sick you're not healthy enough to get your fillings removed but if you're pretty stable and you're feeling well
you should go to a biological dentist to get that checked out you do want to get them removed correctly with a you know a mercury vacuum in a rubber dam placed and nasal cannula in you want to do it correctly to biological dentist who knows what they're doing but everybody should have their mercury on their mouths.
Any other questions all right where we will see you all in two days and I'll be praying for all you guys all right bye bye bye.